[Applause]
cool came out saying a van had hit his
number of pedestrians on underbridge
Westminster Bridge was still very much
in our memory you know how that attack
was carried out now we have a call that
three men left the van and I attacking
members of the public and we just knew
were like oh that's that's that's very
bad we just have to go there
these officers were among the first to
reach the scene on the night of London
Bridge armed only with their
police-issue battens they faced three
knife wielding attackers who'd already
stabbed multiple people in nearby
Borough Market three of them stood at
this dinner line holding holding knives
one of them was raising it above his
head they were shouting at us and
straight away I drew my baton and just
tried to get on the radio and tell
everyone where they were the officers
tracked the trio helping guide armed
response units to the scene ten minutes
after they launched their attack the
terrorists were dead shot by firearms
officers who arrived as the men were
stabbing another of their victims
already thinking I'm gonna get shot
because I was stood there perfectly in
line with is like me one of the
attackers and the firearms officer the
doors come open I thought this is this
is not looking very good so I've sort of
dived myself one way into a shutter
just as the attack has been been shot I
went then to a cordon and you just see
victims everywhere and then you can see
the scale of this attack and then I
walked past the van they used and then I
saw Molotov cocktails at that point I
was I was way that is maybe more of them
not only three of them authorities say
they did all they could to prevent the
attack on London Bridge but the inquest
heard of multiple occasions where
intelligence on the attackers was known
about but little of any action took
place this is the brother-in-law of
London Bridge ringleader Karambit
he confronted but on several occasions
concerned about his descent into violent
extremism
I was concerned for my children and I
made the decision that I need that he
needs to be watched as current BOTS
views became increasingly alarming news
Mandar even called the anti-terrorist
hotline I was doing it for everyone you
know I'm trying to do it for the eight
people that died for the fifty that were
injured you know we always get huge off
not doing enough to curb extremism in
our in our community so it was for that
the contents of that call were never
passed on to mi5 or counter-terror
detectives Khurram but had been under
partial surveillance because of his
known extremist links but that failed to
pick up on the group's preparations for
the attack
the families of those who died believe
opportunities were missed but ultimately
the responsibility lies with the three
attackers who also died and who the
inquest jury concluded were lawfully
killed by police firearms officers mark
white Sky News